now what are the coolest things about
complex members right we're not going to
explore all the ins and outs of this
Integris approximately five weeks so
we're not going to do that right now one
of the coolest things about complex
numbers is that you can represent them
in different ways that are suited to
different kinds of problems okay now I
know that sounds a bit weird you know
having the same number wearing different
clothes I want to do that
what does that even look like but you've
been doing this for years actually what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to put a
number on the board okay don't shout it
out I just want you to have a look at
this number and think about how you
would say it
okay I'm deliberately not using any
digits because that's kind of the point
so the number I'm going to put on there
is what I'm going to shade in green okay
okay I just look at this for a moment
this is a number okay now just want you
to think think
and on the count three I'm gonna ask you
all to tell me how you would say or
write this number okay you ready all at
the same time okay that's a number how
would you say it right count of three
one two three okay so I heard at least
three different answers
you're all the same time so I kind of
didn't quite there for me more okay I
can think of at least four ways to write
this number okay and depending on what
you were thinking cuz I deliberately
didn't give you any sort of lead into
this depending on what you thought that
represented you could say that in a few
different ways here the ways I've got I
heard one point seven five for sure but
we have a name for this kind of
representation what we call it we call
it decimal but um you know the ancient
Greeks who done so much with rational
numbers they they had no system for
decimals right so I'm pretty sure I
heard someone say something to do with a
fraction what did they say yeah okay now
you since seven eight
that's fine cuz I again I didn't give
you any leading I kind of intended these
as two holes right so if each of these
are separate hole this is really
she's seven quarters yes seven quarters
okay because like one two three four
five six seven
what do we call this representation this
is an improper fraction how else how
else could I say I could do as a mixed
numeral right the mixed numeral and I
would say one end one of three quarters
right this will go away which which I
can think of quickly which is a
percentage right so I would say this is
a hundred and seventy five percent as it
as a percent now these are all the same
number
they are just wearing different clothes
and each one the reason why we've learnt
so many different ways of saying the
same thing like you know well just think
we have like a Sulak number of ways of
writing this right like five right x
double-dot do you have the tv-tv oh yeah
XD you get the idea
okay why do we have so many different
ways of saying the same thing yeah old
on a second aren't they all the same
thing aren't they all acceleration no
the same thing but very good same
concept but it's like well tell me what
you've got
do you notice talking about velocity do
you know stuff about displacement you
know stuff that time to be the other
kind of probably you're trying to solve
you will use a different one right and
in the same way depending on the kind of
problem you're trying to solve or the
trying to do the ID you trying to
express you are using different one of
these okay example um percentages this
would by far the easiest if you wanted
to describe like relative birth I used
to be this and now of this I 135 percent
increase in profits over the last
calendar year something like that if
alternatively maybe you wanted to
describe a difference between a
comparison of quantities right like
ratios between two things well clearly
this is the best one right seven one of
them's got seven one four four parts
okay that's
right if I was comparing this to this so
each one of these has a different kind
of purpose that it leans toward and
complex numbers are the same okay so I'm
going to show you and this is where the
extension two people are going to end
and we're all gonna be in you grandma
make sure you the different ways we can
write visualize a complex number okay
now to help you with that I want you to
think back to these guys right before we
got to combine industry the square
native one let's just think about these
for a second okay what picture do you
have in your head
for what negative numbers ah okay now
the picture in my head I run a criticism
oh this room would sort of work the
picture in my head is on this thing over
here so this is this is this is a switch
right can you draw a switch for me just
do me a favor force is a switch
and the reason why I have a switch in my
mind for negative numbers is because if
you think to like the fundamental
negative number which is negative one
okay you can use it kind of like a
switch and in fact we have used them as
a switch do you remember if I asked you
to solve something like this without a
domain we would have to give all the
list out all the solutions right and it
gets a bit tiresome being that this you
know an infinite number of them so we
would say okay the general solution for
this okay so that negative one in there
it acts kind of like a switch right it's
like it's not going off in this case
it's um it's left right okay it's like
very nice sometimes I want you to shift
planet six to the left
sometimes I want you to go find six to
them right it's all backwards forwards
IP that's all this is